Isaiah Berlin distinguishes
in his book “Two Concepts
Of Liberty” between negative
liberty and positive liberty.
Negative liberty describes the individual
freedom from something: from external constraint,
and from outside interference. It’s the
absence of obstacles within a society.
Positive liberty means freedom to do something:
to act upon one’s will, to take control of one’s
life. It's the possession of the power to proceed
regardless of structural limitations in society.
Sounds confusing? The problems of two
imaginary people illustrate this difference.
This is Frank. He lives in Freeland
with the two things he loves most:
his kids and his weights. And then
there is Lilly. She lives in Liberty,
values justice above all, and
dreams of becoming a judge.
But both face lots of obstacles.
To Frank, there is nothing more important
than his health and his family. He gets up
very early for his routines and then takes the
children to school. He pays strict attention
to his diet and his kids' education and
looks down on people who neglect both.
He doesn’t like the authorities. In Freeland, they
collect lots of taxes to fund the public health
care system. Why pay the medical bills for those
that don’t care about their health, he wonders.
Frank seeks freedom from these taxes.
Frank loves to lift weights in front of his
house once the kids are in bed. Yet recently,
Freeland prohibited working out in public
after 10 pm. For Frank, that’s none of the
government's business. He wants freedom from
laws that restrict his recreational habits.
And there is one more thing.
Frank also doesn’t like public schools.
He thinks they are useless and would
prefer to teach his kids at home. But
in Freeland homeschooling is illegal.
Frank thinks that is outrageous and
wants freedom from compulsory education.
Eventually, he’s had enough and moves
to Liberty where the taxes are lower,
the government smaller, and where he believes he’s
got greater freedom from external constraints.
Lilly is already there and feels trapped.
Lilly recently tripped and broke her leg. Now
she needs surgery but medical treatments are
expensive in Liberty. To pay for it, Lilly has
to take out a loan. She thinks the system is
unfair and feels she doesn’t have the freedom
to receive decent affordable health care.
And things get worse.
After her surgery, Lilly needs to rehabilitate
and takes walks around the block. This is when
she realizes that she hates the smoke from
all the cars on the street. The smog she
inhales is clearly dangerous. Lilly finds
she has no freedom to recover appropriately.
This injustice reminds Lilly day in and
day out that she wants to become a judge.
But since she’s from a disadvantaged
family, she can’t afford the tuition
fees of a university. And to take out
another loan scares her. Eventually,
she just feels frustrated and bitter. She
thinks she has no freedom to pursue her dreams.
Lilly isn’t happy in Liberty and moves
to Freeland with a stronger welfare
state. A place where she has the power to act
regardless of structural limitations in society.
Supporters of negative liberty
tend to sympathize with classical
libertarian thoughts. They think of
the state as a coercive force that
limits individual freedom and prefer a small
government with few taxes and regulations.
Advocates of positive liberty tend to identify as
social liberals. They usually want a big welfare
state that ensures a fair redistribution of
wealth and provides equal access to opportunities.
What about you? Which kind of freedom do you want
for yourself? And do you think Isaiah Berlin’s
theory, “the two concepts of liberty”, is right or
wrong? Share your thoughts in the comments below!
If you like how we explain complicated
ideas in simple cartoon animation,
you can support us. Visit patreon.com/sprouts,
just visit us, learn how it works, and what’s
in it for you. We hope to see you there!
And if you are a parent, or an educator,
check our website sproutsschools.com.
There you’ll find this and other video lessons,
additional resources, and classroom activities.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com.